if you know about Montreal you've
probably heard about a few centons it's
known for its European architecture and
cobblestone streets if the origin of the
world-famous Cirque de Soleil and it's
home to the best poutine in the world
but it's also known for its nightlife
now we know our strippers paid hourly
here is that right it's not a system
it's art a performance of eSports fans
associate Montreal with lensman
controversy Montreal is the only
Canadian city where Dreamhack runs
tournaments and one particular
tournament was the beginning of the end
for immortals former csgo roster
Dreamhack Montreal 2017 was a pretty
unimportant tournament despite its
$100,000 prize pool it was just too soon
after the Cracow major to draw any
notable teams Krakow was the first major
that immortals qualified for after a
string of failures he's gonna try and
get up and go for the trade off the
ladder quickly free fires to do what
that's gonna do it [ __ ] sides gonna
qualify and tempo storm will fall into
just play this small flipside it should
be yours the smoke is down it's gonna
draw it won't play he's laughing at but
boy from upper is gonna secure flip site
for a bit longer immortals to fight with
us he picks that one versus two they
pinch in but now the site is against
them and that's how it ends g2 on a
lovely shot from body will find their
way to the major they perpetually played
a little brother to their brazilian
countrymen into luminosity gaming and
later sk gaming partially because
they're aged but also because of their
worse results at krakow their
inexperience shown in the groups but
they were in their element
come playoffs they fed off the energy of
the crowd and achieved a breakthrough
performance and it's immortals that
might be the ones to take them down
Keith
take the shots right away pan bumps out
and we've got five Brazilians in this
tournament it's not SK its immortals no
peek and either control as tatts goes it
away - goes to the smoke he won't find
it it's done
[Music]
commiserations to the Brazilians they've
looked fantastic throughout their first
ever nature they made that a grand final
in three months as well it wasn't quite
enough there they come after that event
they were no longer the team that failed
to make the majors again and again they
were no longer eske's little brothers
there were teams that demanded respect
in the offseason multiple reports came
out that immortals were going through
some internal issues and might face
roster changes immortals roster remain
unchanged but they headed it into their
first event post crack out tree
McMasters Malmo with a cloud hanging
over their heads they had a decent
showing in Malmo and in advance to the
playoffs over fnatic but fell to north
after a tight quarterfinal steal gets
dropped and Heddy goes for the peak it
was a disappointing finish for the major
grand finalists but some fans brushed it
off as growing pains for a young roster
but there were plenty of questions for
mortals heading into Dreamhack Montreal
aside from North Montreal featured a
lower tier of competition in the major a
majority of the teams were from the
Americas so expectations were high for
immortals and they didn't disappoint but
I'll see the 30 seconds we'll get caught
out bolts gets the first look into my
second in there you have it immortals
the big brother will prevail that a
finesse though it needs to go to the
site in Flint at the time is low and he
realizes that he knows he's around here
somewhere but oh and he actually thought
he went away but turns throughout the
last second plant will go down finessing
out in the open but heady he's just
ready to take this palace pit back
though taking it and there you have it
ladies and gentlemen it's gonna be
immortals that take control of our first
semifinal here immortals earned a spot
in the grand finals against North the
team that eliminated them from Malmo
just a week prior so immortals went into
the series with a chip on their
shoulders well two of them did bolts and
Steel showed up on time but but what we
are waiting on is the immortals who are
well they're not quite seated just yet
but any moment
hopefully it will be it will be an
immortals freshened up and sitting down
after that performance earlier that
landed them here in fact they took so
long to arrive at the venue that
immortal or Hannah the default map wall
well guess what guys I have an Easter
Egg for you and it is that we will not
be seeing the first map of Mirage it
does look like The Immortals have
forfeited it due to being late to the
stage and to playing and that's just the
way the cookie crumbled I suppose I
don't really know what else to say about
that other than the process needs to be
respected and rules by tournament
organizers need to be respected and the
right thing is certainly I believe right
here with the Brazilian side already
down a map Kimura was undoubtedly low
and the rest of the series went about
the way you'd expect yeah well if North
won to win before they sure enough it's
over
he's the up close will be tested and
he's praised / 3 Lucas with a trade
though and immortals with an entry
chance conf a ghost shut it all down
though getting behind of the chance
John sometimes during the series then
CLG coach steve ryu beretta casa tweeted
that the team had been late for their
series earlier that day and that he had
heard that some of the players had been
out the night before partying fifteen
minutes after that CLG player FNS
tweeted that he was disappointed to have
been eliminated by hungover players it
didn't take long for the immortals
players to notice FNS and Lucas 1 had a
back and forth that and then relatively
peacefully but a Angie's response was
last week and it didn't end there
according to FNS he was told to leave
the hotel he was staying at
because KNG was going through the hall
looking for him I was in my hotel room
whatever was talking Shawn and then I'm
like I'm hungry let's go along cheese or
something and I go downstairs and a
person I'm not going to name walks up to
me and says hey man like you're really
really just like you gotta go you gotta
and I'm like what's going on and he's
like dude like you tweeted this and I
understand that it was a joke but can G
like is not happy with you right now and
he's looking for you and I'm like I
don't know what to say to that can we
just pause for a second and talk about
how insane this is here's F NS a guy
from Canada who makes a living playing
video games what more could you ask for
he just also set and was feeling cheeky
so he spouted a tweet that was edgy and
self-deprecating and as he was getting
ready to head out someone stopped him
and told him he had to leave the hotel
because there was somebody stalking the
halls looking for him this was no longer
just a joke for FNX and for all the
information I got is I need to leave
this guy's temper is out of control
I gotta go and I'm like some in my head
I'm thinking like why is he looking for
me because the way normally the way
people are confronted me usually is just
like they message me or they come up to
me and say hey Lee what you did was
messed up it's understandable for things
to get heated in a competitive space and
it's easy to brush things like this off
especially when the medium is as distant
and impotent of a tweet but a death
threat no matter where it comes from
should never be taken lightly I've been
thinking about killing you in real life
lately
not nice homey Jesus all I do is play
video games man actually I'm gonna uh
I'm gonna report that guy to the police
balls here and report this to twitch I
[Music]
love you CompTIA I was kidding that was
boring had to get it lit I've donated
one cave check your PayPal donation is
damn I feel bad now what the [ __ ] dude
that's not that's not something joke
about man
and I only saw one donation from you and
it was that one threatened someone's
life bro
I'm joking not ridiculous despite all
the commotion and hearsay
no one ever actually provided proof that
KNG was stalking the halls looking for
evidence but it kind of didn't matter if
you put a sign in everything that was he
said she said and regardless of whether
the source is trustworthy or reputable
the facts remain immortals were late for
a Grand Finals something unheard of and
top tier competition eSports or
otherwise and Kenji went on to make a
very public death threat on Twitter all
eyes were on those moments there was
nothing to prove so things were bad
should immortals have been late for
their match no should f NS have made
that joke probably not should k ng have
made those death threats absolutely not
but the aftermath had an even more
lasting effect
several of the immortals players
apologized for the lackluster grand
finals regardless of how it happened
including KNG but two months after the
incident there wasn't any closure
between FNS and k ng no there's not been
any like contact with kin G as far as
like any of that stuff pretty sure he
still hates me but as far as like
everybody else I think I'm chill with us
when it happened I was ready to talk to
him but he was like kind of upset
obviously and so he didn't want to have
any conversation with me or rather his
coach told me just not to bother but
yeah I did try at first but now it's
like kind of water under the bridge and
even if he did apologize it would do
little to erase his threat from the
public record things in parts of the
csgo community who
Bewdley turn into a meme we should not
for sure Kenji but the death threat
itself had a lasting negative impact on
Candy's career somebody also needs to
chill like he's trying to get he's
applying for a visa right now like if
they google his name if they look any of
this stuff it's not good for him you
know that I mean like he needs that he
should be in damage control mode KNG was
put on the chopping block but his four
teammates and coach convinced him Wordle
CEO Noah Winston to let him stand
but then he violated his internal
suspension and his contract was
immediately terminated and it's not a
part of immortals and will never again
be a part of the noise Noah Rin the risk
of pissing off his players for the sake
of principle and that's exactly what
happened the Telus twins quickly
requested a transfer once they heard the
news that tangi was gone but it was a
decision that was almost universally
praised by the eSports community
ultimately though I don't want this to
be the conclusion of this sordid saga
I was not left with many options if we
wanted to preserve the philosophies and
the ideals that immortals as a brand
stands for though it is unfortunate that
valve rules means that the three players
no longer with us have control over our
a major slot playing in a major is not
worth more than everything that we stand
for as an organization later the ex
immortals trio and the major spot that
they held were bought by 100 feet we're
permanently moving into the csgo
community and we are teaming up with kin
G Lukas Henny FNX in bit however one
hundred thief players perhaps
unsurprisingly couldn't secure visas in
time and weren't able to attend a major
the team never played a single match
maybe it's Karma
maybe it's justice for them that the 100
these guys didn't make it and I'm not
gonna lie I'm kind of conflicted like I
kind of feel like you know dude good
serves you right but at the same time
you know that you don't want to see that
happen to a team that's trying to make a
living and get to the majors it's hard
to say exactly how much of a part
Montreal played in kgs downfall but it's
obvious that Montreal is where that
downfall began a handful of tweets for
months and however many alleged
encounters
the scenes or all it talked destroy the
career of a truly promising player
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]